-It is great to see you.
You look fantastic.
-I know, right?
[ Laughter ]
-It's been a while --
-You know what it is?
-What?
-I've been eating vegetables
with every meal and lipo.
-Oh, my God.
Wow. That is perfect.
-Yeah, it's that combination.
-I haven't seen you --
Maybe a couple little events
here and there.
-Yeah.
-But I tell you what --
I see you in the movies.
I see you on TV.
-Yeah.
-I see you're doing commercials.
-That's right, that's right.
You know, I'm friends with
Jennifer Lawrence,
and she is the face of Dior.
And I am the body of mayo.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Did you know that?
-Yes, I did. I saw that.
-I was in a mayonnaise
commercial.
-You were in a mayonnaise
-A mayonnaise commercial.
I feel like my favorite thing is
picturing the marketing meeting
where they were like,
"Who looks like they eat mayo?
Who? Who?"
[ Laughter ]
Somebody was like, "Schumer!"
And they go, "Yes, every meal.
Okay, let's get her
on the horn."
[ Laughter ]
You know?
-It was very funny.
I did get to see that.
But that's not the only company
you work with, right?
-Oh, no. No.
I work with only
the sexiest brands.
-Yeah.
-I am the official vagina
of Tampax.
[ Laughter ]
-That's an honor.
Congratulations.
-I'm sorry that you missed out.
I know you were in the running.
[ Laughter ]
I'm the face of --
-Congratulations.
-Yeah, they searched
far and wide for the perfect --
the vagina they wanted
to represent their brand.
-Wow.
-And do you know what my
favorite thing is about that?
'Cause I really am
a spokesperson for them.
In between the time
I signed on with them,
I had a hysterectomy,
which, if you don't know,
that's when you get your uterus
taken out.
-Yeah, that's right.
-And look, I'm no doctor.
-No.
-But when you don't have
a uterus,
do you know what
you don't get anymore?
-Periods.
-Bing, bing, bing, bing, bing.
-All right, there you are.
Yeah, thank you. Yeah, yeah.
Wow.
-Yeah.
I know they wanted to fire me,
but yeah.
Of course. "Of course I want you
to stay on.
Of course, even though you don't
get the thing that..."
-Yeah, you're spokesperson,
yeah.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
-Yeah. Very sexy.
-It's an honor.
-If you have a sexual product...
[ Laughter ]
-Talk to Amy Schumer.
-Mayo and tampons.
-You know, I do want to
applaud you because
over the past few years,
you've been very open about
health issues that you've had.
-Thank you. Yes.
I feel like it's
really important.
People don't really speak,
especially women.
I have endometriosis,
which 10% of women have,
but, like, you know,
it's so undiagnosed.
And when I was pregnant, I had
something called hyperemesis,
which means you're violently ill
through your whole pregnancy.
And, you know, Kate Middleton
had it.
Cindy Crawford had it.
So it was like, "Let me guess."
[ Laughter ]
Of course I'm next
because I'm like them, you know?
Visually.
I'm like them visually.
-Yes, visually, of course.
I think it's good
that you're doing it.
-Yeah.
-I think it's helpful to get it
out there and get the
conversation going and talking.
-Share what's going on,
you know?
And I was so happy
to be diagnosed
because I was like,
"Okay, great. What do we do?"
You know? Now we know what it
was, what do people do?
And they said, "Oh, well, we
haven't been able to study it
because it only
happens to women."
[ Laughter ]
"And we really only focus on
male medicine. You know?
But if your husband wants,
we have a chewable Viagra."
[ Laughter ]
Okay? That's a real product.
-We figured that out.
-It's real.
-That was the problem with
Viagra.
-Because sometimes it's scary
to take a pill, right?
It's scary.
-Yeah, it's a little scary.
-What if it gets stuck?
[ Laughter ]
"I don't want it."
-Let's make it chewable.
Let's get the scientists
working on --
-A chewable one. Yeah.
-Let's get the doctors
working on it.
-Around the clock,
Johns Hopkins,
a lot of white coats.
-Yeah.
-But what about my endometri--
"No, we're sorry.
We're really sorry." Yeah.
-"We'll figure that out
some other year."
-Yeah, some other time.
-I will say you have
a beautiful, beautiful boy.
What is he --
What is the baby into?
What is he into right now?
-He loves trucks, of course.
-Yeah.
-Which is such
a convenient thing.
You know, if your kid loves
dinosaurs --
I just take him outside
in New York City.
I'm like, "Here's your Disney."
You know?
There's cars all over.
[ Laughter ]
-Trucks, everything, yeah.
-My husband and I,
we read to him
at night because we're heroes.
[ Laughter ]
And just really
beautiful people.
-Yeah, please sit down.
Please sit down, everyone.
-Thank you so much.
-Yeah, thank you.
-I'm doing God's work.
-We'll add applause later.
-Just like a really big --
-A big, thunderous applause.
-Maybe some footage of
the standing ovation.
-What are you reading?
-I have such a bad habit.
Well, we love your book,
of course.
-Thank you.
-But I keep doing this thing
where if there's even like
a slightly attractive
blonde woman that I could
maybe look like,
I fish for compliments,
so I'll be like --
In like "Goldilocks
and the Three Bears,"
I'm like,
"Who does that look like?"
[ Laughter ]
And he's like, "Mommy."
And I'm like,
"Oh, my God, thank you."
[ Laughter ]
-You make him. Yeah.
-And then the bears,
and he's like, "Mommy."
I'm like, "No, no, no, no."
-"No, yeah, no, no.
Yeah, I'm not a bear."
-"Let's go back to the...
-Goldilocks. Yeah.
-"...the pretty one." Yeah.
-I want to hear
about the new show.
"Life & Beth," very, very funny.
And we'll talk about more stuff.
More with Amy Schumer after the
break. Come on back, everybody.